hi I'm Nick Gillespie with reason TV and
today we're talking with Emily Ekins
she's polling director at Reason
Foundation and she runs the reason roop
pole a quarterly survey of what's going
on in America Emily thanks for talking
thanks for having me in the latest poll
will run through a bunch of the results
and talk about a couple in detail but
the budget you found that most Americans
want the government to spend less than
they did last year yes and this is
really interesting given that the
proposal for next year is to spend more
than we spend last year and that's how
we asked them and a majority of
Americans want the federal budget to
spend less next year than it did this
year for health care you found that most
Americans dislike the health care law
that's going to go into effect in
january first 2014 yes we asked this
question a little bit differently than
most we asked people did you like the
health care when it passed but then
change your mind did you like it and you
still like it did you dislike it when it
passed and you still dislike it or did
you dislike it then you changed your
mind most people say that they dislike
the law and most people didn't change
their mind with gun control gun control
was a huge issue after the Newtown
shooting last December the Senate tried
to pass gun control law it didn't happen
what are what were people saying about
gun control yeah we wanted to ask about
that because before the debate there
were poles out showing that ninety
percent of americans favored background
checks for for gun purchases and so when
the senate voted down the legislation
people assumed people be up in arms
about it we found out that that's not
true we asked americans that they wanted
the Senate to go back debate and vote on
gun control again or if they wanted the
Senate to move on sixty-two percent said
they wanted the Senate to move on Social
Security was one of the featured topics
in this version of the poll you found
that most people have a favorable view
of Social Security yes most people do
have a favorable view of Social Security
they also seem to view social security
as a retirement fund which they're
paying into throughout throughout their
whole lives that will finance their
retirement later on only about a third
of Americans see it as a transfer
program where you're
hang for the benefits of current seniors
right which is a more accurate
understanding harbor now Social Security
is often called her it was originally
called the third rail of American
politics elected officials and people
running for office never wanted to talk
about it because to even suggest
changing it would mean you would never
get elected which is part of the reason
why it's going to go broke in 2033 what
did you find when when are people
willing to talk about entitlement reform
for Social Security so most polls keep
showing us that people are very opposed
to any change to entitlements what we
did is we set up a series of trade-off
questions almost like a conversation
where we gave people information about
the current financial situation of
social social security where they
learned that they wouldn't get back as
much as they put in once people learn
those things they actually are open to
reform but there's no consensus I think
what's happening is that we're not
talking about it people are unaware of
what's going on and as a result that's
why they seem unwilling to change a
program they don't know is flawed one of
the other things that the reason root
poll does that's a very unique and
different and a particular interest
people who read reason is that you track
libertarian sentiment among the
population explain how you get to that
you know how you measure that and then
where are we in terms of how many
libertarian leaning voters are there in
America yes so we asked three questions
on every survey we've been doing this
since 2011 are the three questions
basically gauge attitudes towards the
proper role of government in economic
affairs and social affairs we use those
questions to determine those who want
more government or less government in
person in Social Affairs and those who
want more or less in economic affairs
and that creates about four groups as
well as kind of those in the middle that
aren't really consistent and how they
answer those questions and when you do
that you find about twenty percent or so
of Americans provide a more libertarian
response to questions about government's
involvement in our social lives and our
economic lives and then finally just
explain very quickly the methodology of
the poll this is a national survey and
it's you know it isn't reason readers
it's actually a really good
cross-section of
people are thinking yes this is a
national survey we call thousand adults
on landlines and cellphones it's
actually fifty percent landline fifty
percent cell phone all right well great
Emily Ekins thank you for talking to
recent TV she's the director of the
reason route poll of Reason Foundation
thanks very much thanks